ist das ein video was einfach
zwischendurch kommt das nicht besonders
ist aber übel school du macht mehr
videos als nur eins die woche ich habe
mich hiermit studie getroffen denn er
ist neben mir einer der feinsten gaumen
die youtube deutschland zu bieten hat
wir sind beide essens experten und noch
dazu ist freddy beim bestellen
ja ich bestelle seit jahren viel ich
bestelle kräftig stelle völlig kurbeln
die wirtschaft an ich bin kapitalist pur
und du bestellst auch in youtube-videos
und hast wirklich da nicht die
allermeisten sachen schon probiert und
ich dachte mir ich will auch haben da
einfach was neues probieren einfach mal
nicht wieder bei einem standard pc laden
bestellt deshalb lassen wir heute den
zufall entscheiden was wir beiden uns
jetzt zu gemüte führt ihr seht hier oben
bestelle von 340 restaurants gibt 70
kategorien also bestimmen wir jetzt als
erstes die kategorie das könnte jetzt
sowas sein wie italienische pizza dann
gibt es glaube ich noch 150 restaurants
von 340 ja es könnte aber auch spareribs
da weil du alles randomized random
restaurant wird bestellt sagt mir eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 70 habe ich so
unglaublich gespannt sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 70 41
also das sind 13 39 und meeresfrüchte
aber moment meeresfrüchte kann auch
jedes italienische restaurant das kann
gut sein
wir gehen mal drauf okay wir haben eine
überschaubare auswahl 12345 wir haben
chinesische indische italienisch und
nochmal technisch müssen wir denn dann
da die meeresfrüchte bestellen das
wirklich durch den super mensch dass du
dich fragt freundlich hast du mir dass
ich die krise
die sache ist wir bestellen dann zwei
drei verschiedene sachen per zufall und
irgendwas wird schon ohne - ruhig sein
okay sagt mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 5
nach 1 chinesischen meeresfrüchte
händchen das ist ein klassisches ding wo
es alles gibt aber immerhin vier sternen
geben die bewertung mit bewertungen
lesen essen
die bestellung wurde das egal essen war
fast kalt und die lieferung kam 40
minuten zu spät nicht noch mal gucken
wir gar nicht weiter ein
wir gucken jetzt erst mal aus welcher
kategorie wir bestellen acht kategorien
sagen wir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 8 6
das früchte spezialität gar als auch das
gebracht werden und gebratenen
tintenfisches 100 traum mit gemüse
gebackene stehen jetzt firma tram curry
um himmels willen vermachte unsere
firmen meeresfrüchte spezialitäten auf
welche jetzt zu besonders ist er
gebackene hummer krabben würde ich sagen
ja glaube ich wäre auch für mich das
neueste sagen eine zahl zwischen 1 und 4
gebratenen tintenfisches das ist
wirklich was was ich nicht essen werde
mit gebratenen reis nudeln geboten heißt
haben das gj 12 euro einfach mal machen
wir noch eine neue kategorie dann jetzt
ja wir gehen einen die kategorien 1 bis
8 1 besagt man eine zeit zwischen 1 und
eigentlich vorspeise sehr gut vier
verschiedene sagt mir eine zahl zwischen
1 und 4 4 gebackener brokkoli diese
bestell und die wir da gleich abschicken
hat noch niemals irgendjemand gemacht
oder mitgebrachten thunfisch was geht
mich nämlich so freut dass du sagst
lassmann bestell video drehen aber ich
hab so ein tricks aber du brauchst auf
jeden fall auch ein hauptgericht sagte
eine kategorie zwischen 1 und 8 9
sagen wir eine karte sagt mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 8 7 kommt dass wir jetzt
erstmal sechs spezialitäten des hauses
ok ich freue mich die 123 da ist ein
schicksal selbst bestimmt
sagt mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 11 4
13 34 hühnerfleisch mit brokkoli
entschuldigung nicht jemals persönlich
getan hast gebrauchtwagen von
gruppenleader der ball tatsächlich ich
hätte gern reist dann drücke dann machen
wir ein bisschen gesünder sollen wir
noch ein letztes mal vielleicht
vielleicht erwischen wir noch ein
getränk oder eine vorspeise sind sagen
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 8 236 sagt mir
eine zeit zwischen 1 und 6 1 peking
suppe schaaf wir haben also gebratenen
tintenfisches gebracht nach rechts
gebackener brokkoli pikant hühnerfleisch
mit brokkoli mit reis für pekings
beschaffen so sehen uns gleich wenn das
essen angekommen ist so fragil da sind
unsere feinsten speisen was war das hier
nochmal das war eine pikante suppe
bestimmt auch wieder mal alles weil alle
täglich 35 euro und für diese bestellung
gesagt find ich schon knackig muss ich
sagen so früh stellen erst mal sagen
peking suppe scharf und sauer kommt noch
das ding auf probiert er als erstes eine
mysteriöse konsistenz so sieht nämlich
diese suche aus also so ein bisschen
mysteriös aber es riecht schon wie so
eine süße soße ist nicht nur natürlich
sauer
mir darf laver ich finde so als hätte
mal einfach so eine süße so ist also mit
wasser ausgeschüttet wie gekocht ja ja
genau und dann halt schicken kleine
machen wo wir da flavour man alter
verstehst übermenschen sich das
freiwillig beständig würste zehn sachen
die ich davor vorstellung auf jeden fall
auf sonntag eine es gibt es hierfür eine
note ich darf eigentlich leute von 0 bis
10 bewerten um ein was ich würde der
sache eine sechseinhalb aus zehn gene
drei deutschen boots ja ich bedanke mich
bei so was auch immer sehr positiv das
würde nicht so eine super strecke schon
betreibt immer darüber reden er zwei
schränke auch mächtig ich denke wirklich
solche süß außen mit wasser
ausgeschüttet würden natürlich trotzdem
leute keine sorge auch gewährt leicht
und ich würde sagen das wird
wahrscheinlich nächste vorspeise seien
hier gebackener brokkoli pikant let's go
damit hätte ich jetzt nicht sagen weil
oleg darüber gekippt bekannt heißt es
guckt euch das an hier also wirklich wie
stürmischer meinte zambrano lag ich weiß
nicht aber es ist halt einfach wie der
typische das ist glaube ich dass cage
die der veganer
das wäre das der blumenkohl schicken
sieht aber aus wie so ein geist schicken
ps wenn ich das stimmt ja also scheibe
sieht es nicht aus
wahrscheinlich das stimmt allerdings ist
wirklich nicht durch ich von außen sieht
es aus von innen ist aber einfach nur ja
sehr weich für sieben euro drohten ich
das gar nicht ab das ist so ein 4 euro
denke ich weißt du wieviel du das selber
machen können dass für sieben euro da
können wir glaube ich eine große familie
ernähren für sieben euro wenn du das
einfach selber machen sodass du kannst
es essen aber alle davon wird sichtbar
mich ganz ehrlich ist für mich nur
sieben von zehn ich muss konnten eine
halbe stufe höher gehen aber eigentlich
war das auch seine sechste und das ist
das 1 5 das mit vier das ist bei mir
nämlich auch eine 5 würde ich sagen weil
du kannst essen alle davon würde ich
aber vielleicht machen mäßig nicht
empfehlen bisher keine große freude
wir haben bei dem laden wird das hier
nicht so richtig gut mache gebratenen
tintenfisches
und wir gucken nein das ist der hit
beratene tintenfisch es sieht ultra
gummi aus aber ich will jetzt nicht so
schnell ich dachte unfall wie ist damit
gebraten
das ist nicht erst nicht gebracht das
ist einfach nur heiß gemacht oder so
eine sauce rein ja also ich probiere
jetzt den teams beschränkt ist auch
wirklich nichts was ich mir bestellen
würde ich komplett raus tut mir leid
also display geschmack ist aber ich
hasse auch fisch also die konsistenz
gummi gebratene reich ist nicht geplant
dass wirklich nur ein aspekt der sollte
einige brachten sind weder die
tintenfischringe noch der reichen
gebraten übrig die enttäuschung vieler
für vier von fünf sternen ohne schirm
firma euro
das ist schon richtig ja also der weiß
man warum man auch gerne und viel selber
kommt überzeugt mich nicht kriegt von
mir eine viereinhalb was war das letzte
ist bei mir zwei brokkoli schicken und
wir kommen zum letzten paket wirklich
leute ich muss das mal ganz kurz wie
hast du das sie gerade so durch muss
halt ganz kurz hier ins bett zurück
machen und feststellen dass das wirklich
eine enttäuschung ist also wurde ich
immer belohnt wenn ich sachen
ausprobiert habe und wir machen auf das
letzte gericht
du hast jetzt den gebratenen reis bohnen
solltest also anscheinend ist ein
bisschen was durcheinander gesagt wir
haben hier eine kleine glibber soße
es ist bratensoße auch damit das gerät
ist für freunde ich glaube auch ohne ein
gedicht hörer früher ist das oder so
sieht aber muss ich ehrlich sagen am
besten aus von einsamen bisher und ich
teste das jetzt auch machen ist für mich
auch wohl wieder durchweg solide aber
ich fühle mich auch so ein 8 euro wenn
also leute da muss ich sagen da hat mich
ein bisschen teurer sagst du hier
bildungsmäßig ist beim sex ist das beste
was ich da geben würde
für fernsehen geben aber ich hab's
gesehen das hier ist unsere auswahl und
ich bin enttäuscht war auf jeden fall
mal ein interessantes video so aus der
reihe war ich das öfter ich weiß es
nicht falls euch sehr gut gefällt dann
ja sex tape ist natürlich im titel
verlinkt wie gewohnt und wie sonst beim
nächsten mal